all right so how big of a threat is
China to business culture and the world
in terms of unleashing another pandemic
why would Ayanna Presley try and
minimize that when it is such a big
problem
for her being woke is more important
than being alive if Alana Presley was
president
we can only get tough with white
countries Russia the French who I'm kind
of itching for a fight with if if you're
Japan if you're China if you're the
cartels if you're a Muslim Nation you
know what bring it on we're just gonna
lay down because we don't want to offend
anybody do you remember that attitude
during the war on terror yeah you want
to get too tough with these Muslims you
know because islamophobia that is the
real threat so take away the trade
defense policy take away everything just
as you said um covet alone yep they
unleash this disease that murders a
million Americans and you're sitting in
Congress you're like you know what
I'd rather talk about infrastructure I I
don't know who her constituents are
um
I can't imagine they support that her
constituents died from covet 19. I think
their families might want to get tough
on China maybe and it might have been
America that was involved in that lab so
if you know she's America hater another
reason to look into it yeah I mean there
are so many questions China obviously
has a 50-year strategy for achieving
Global hegemony uh the United States we
have a different strategy based on who's
president but what the message they're
sending in Congress is we want to
protect ourselves as a nation we want to
have a policy about China that is not
necessarily a partisan I think that
while I am generally speaking
sympathetic to the squad I like AOC a
lot I like her her Verve her grit uh her
energy uh the problem is that they get
off on these tangents that are so silly
to to worry about people being
anti-china because of uh you know uh
these these actions that they're taking
is ridiculous when you think China is
the Menace it's far more threatening to
the United States Russia is under 200
million China is a billion in some
hundred millions I think that China will
represent our future adversary for
Forever Until something awful happens
and I I got it doesn't
go down micro shrink it down now to
anti-asian sentiment in the city and and
in other places
with many Asian friends I can tell you
particularly the women are petrified uh
you know obviously a notorious case
brings it to the fore but they live in
the in a in a constant sense that there
is that they are different that they
will be singled out that that every
person of color that they walk past Ben
that is a Potential Threat to them it's
it's really very very sad what has
happened and I think that wokeness
doesn't help what should what the
approach should be is frankness
confronted inclusion real inclusion not
BS uh you know uh uh PR stuff like this
I wonder what her position is on the
Supreme Court case in regards to the
Asian American students from Harvard
that's a good question who are saying
that they've been discriminated against
I mean maybe the most discriminated
against group in higher education you
know arguably so the the data bears that
out and you know it's like that's not
even being politically correct can you
uh speak honestly to that and you
haven't heard a peep